avete presente quando siete in casa
state cercando il vostro animale
domestico e incredibilmente l'animale
domestico si nasconde da voi perché può
fate schifo
ecco è quello che succede col mio cane
però a prescindere dalla situazione qua
esiste un gioco chiamato in ten kate
vediamo come funziona ecco qua allora
abbiamo sedi cocco locchi oscar tiger
papa all cleo felix mittens molli e
bandit ok
partiamo subito con barba seguito al
caso scusami eh vabbè ma me li trova
questo era cocco ho capito ma io li vedo
i gatti e cioè il prossimo di carne a
casa
sicuramente qualcuno mi compare e di
questo cliccando a caldo e scusami non
vale
ecco dentro allora è molto più facile
libero forks bene ho fatto il suo
effetto
va bene facciamolo per bene dai anche se
effettivamente potrebbe evitare di farlo
cliccando su tutti i gatti che ci sono
104 questo qua è morto non puoi star
dormendo aveva raccolto noi ho fatti
tutti i tiger ai software lens gates of
the pound staring to realize guarda
all'orizzonte quindi qua grande tiger
babbo sa perché è messo in una posizione
strana come files
eccolo non è lui e solid snake a una a
una cosa veramente strana con la coda
così quindi è strano che io non lo vedo
questo qua era l'altro sicuramente
guarda zio ti si è nascosto veramente
bene alla fine perché io giuro non ti
vedo eccolo lì che ho cliccato a caso
non l'avevo visto mai davvero male
indoor vuol dire che sta dentro qualcosa
dentro un edificio
però si sa ma a hector pirla non l'ho
visto la finestra ma bello proprio lui
mi trovo a tutti gli ufo ma o tipo i
pokémon come è finito ma no ma no era
fortissimo ma basta ma dai ma era facile
dai per favore
tutte le forme un altro non è peraltro è
un altro gioco di gatti che si
nascondono questo un video di youtube
siamo ridotti a questo perché il video
era troppo corto a me questo era facile
perché ha trovati gli altri ma è più
difficile
questo è diventato sto gioco
eccolo eccolo qui in basso a destra l'ho
trovato sta qua ha nascosto
aspettando che qualcuno passi per a
graffiarsi lo stinco a graffiare di un
nuovo verbo è questo sarà mimetizza
tissimo qua ragazzi qua non lo so vi
giuro che non lo vedo qua vi giuro non
lo sto veramente vedendo come boccaccio
[Musica]
a ae questo questo è questo qua o no
e questo che non è un gatto questo è un
gatto teoricamente questo qui è questo
che non è un pupazzo non è un pupazzo
teoricamente questo qua pagano non sto
vedendo neanche col cerchio io ma che
cazzo ma dove
ma dove ah è vero questa è la coda e
questo è il gatto madonna non avevo
visto proprio che pirla mi avete
sbagliato
per questo è facile meno male che ho
detto che facile lo trovo acqua michiara
so che va bene la passata dalle cose
difficilissime a delle cagate allora
questo quasi sicuramente non è un gatto
però questo lo è quello destro perfetto
davvero male che si è passati dalle cose
quello che non ho trovato la
difficilissima queste sono le cagate in
confronto
allora ce n'è uno finto qui dio mio
quando lo vedrai cagherà i mattoni porca
vacca bruttissimo c'è bruttissimo c'è
uno sguardo spiritato gatto va bene ma
ridotti a questo ragazzo mio cane si è
ridotto a trovare gatti guardiamo video
di gatti vice ragazzi se questo non è il
canale con più iscritti d'italia kakà
non potrei sapere chi altro potrebbe
farlo abiti dei tappeti attaccati ai
muri voi in casa noi mi faccio questa
roma che non ho mai capito chiarita
pecchia risacca tivoli che cazzo di
attacca i muri i tappeti vano per terra
e come mettere per terra un quadro
c'erano bombe a per questo era di questo
era proprio difficile da trovare
soprattutto è difficile dare il casino
che ha fatto very nice
se prima quando non lo vedi perché c'è
un sacco di nome è sempre in alto
comunque
non so veramente capendo se tutti sti
video di gatti in qualche modo siano
visti dalla gente non ho visto le rese
di sto video e sono veramente curioso di
vederlo dopo averlo red dopo averlo
registrato perché veramente sono mega
curioso cliente finita poi vedere quanto
visto al vostro video 46mila views
complimenti ha fatto anche find the cat
2 che non so quanto valga la pena fare
però find the cat in the field trova il
gatto nel campo questo innanzitutto non
è un campo è tutta merda però vabbè
troviamo il gatto a devo farà in tempo
devo trovarlo pure minchia noi faccio
pagare in stack rosa regata in tempo non
lo troverò mai ma neanche se scopo equa
e questo non lo so ma vi giuro non lo
vedo
questo no ma non vedo niente che la
potesse una scattata
eccolo qua questo qua questo qua
purtroppo alla fine questo punto quindi
ma come ma dove è vero
madonna ragazzi ma questi scattate le
foto con le patate cosa cosa pretendete
no ma non li vedo regalo eccolo minchia
l'ho trovato
non l'avevo visto proprio va benissimo a
questo è già più difficile ok se e vabbè
quindi ripeto scattate veramente male
ste foto porco del demonio come faccio a
trovare un gatto qui mica ditemi se non
l'avete visto secondo non barate sky
temi come ti trovi
eccolo qui hanno trovato subito c'è
subito no ci ho messo quasi tutto il
tempo però guarda qua per i due su tre è
credibile ragazzi basta basta basta
mista rotola c'è questo questa veramente
il punto più alto del mio canale basta
questo più di così non possiamo fare
niente più di così c'è solo penso pietro
e poi dopo forse anche charlie moon però
non lo so basta vero che hai visto vi
sia piaciuto per voi amanti dei gatti
sicuramente chieti a creare schiacciate
da so mi piace e commentate se anche
guardate tratto tutti i gatti fa vige tv
2020 signori che se il canale acquisiti
iscritti in bacio bella
[Musica]